[Musik]
stand damals vor dem ultimatum willst du
die firma wetter machen ja und dann
haben gesagt ja machen aus festen
überzeugung dass du dich schon mal hab
vorher gesagt denke ich bin dreckig weg
nach hause komme arbeit macht spaß das
macht richtig spaß heute gemacht habe
und das wird mir aber egal
handwerksmeister ich bin deutscher
meister wer kann das von sich sagen ich
bin mit ich mache kann anfassbar und
kann ich ja ich bin sehr stolz auf den
film mehr richtig dass ich kann das
machen erstmal ein bisschen jemand
anders aber die idee war da
die idee war judt zwang war nicht also
kein richtiger name ist dennis merten
ich bin bürgermeister dass hinter mir
aus meiner werkstatt dort baue ich
besser roger kübel immer alles aus holz
[Musik]
also mein arbeitstag sieht so aus ich
fange um 6 1 in der firma und macht
meistens bis 18 uhr
und dennoch büro ist halt der chef
selbst und ständig aber ich hab's mir so
ausgesucht und glücklich damit
wenn ein langes wochenende ist mit einem
feiertag krieg hat schmerz am zweiten
tag millionär werden wir nicht mehr aber
das wollen wir eigentlich ohne war muss
sich um die aufträge kümmern wird
vielleicht ende juni alle zu aber das
sei in jedem handwerk so stoßzeiten dass
keine konkrete dauerhaft beschäftigung
mal mehr mal weniger aber wir sind mit
dem zufrieden war
nachwuchssorgen wer will sich noch
dreckig machen und wäre früher stellen
also wir haben eine bundesweite innung
da hat ja in einigen bundesländern gar
kein berufskollegen da gibt es zum
beispiel in berlin mehr
ich glaube mclaren durfte auch keiner
mehr sehr in niedersachsen sieht auch
länger ausschließt wir euch stellen ohne
und damit der bundesweit erinnerung die
sitze und baden württemberg und da sind
noch viele firmen drin weil viele die
berufsbezeichnung noch im firmennamen
haben zum beispiel jetzt bücherei
wäscherei aber die machen fenster
treppen innenausbau und nach dem letzten
stand sind in deutschland sieben firmen
die die wäscherei küferei als
hauptgeschäft machen der boom mit den
holzfässern war im prinzip nie weg
wusste er wurde immer ein bisschen
stiefmütterlich behandelt weil man
wollte mehr quantität als qualität aber
jetzt kommt man doch viel auf die
qualität zurück und da kommst du an dem
holzfass nicht dran vorbei wenn er jetzt
mutet der steel abbauen will und musik
auf dem holzfass packen sonst ist im
prinzip der dom macher der firma
ich meine dass ein produkt ist
qualitativ hochwertiger und wird dann
auch im laden mehr kosten aber sind ja
auch sachen die man genießt und sich
nicht die bohne zu schießen
meine kunden hier für die ich jetzt hier
verbaut gerade dicht fässer um destillat
oder wein einzulagern sind winzer rhein
mosel rhein nahe und ansonsten destillen
schnapsbrennereien hier im umland einmal
zum beispiel werner haben an kunden
genau man bald britischen kunden
ansonsten fiel nach süddeutschland wo
die obstbrenner sitzen für obst fässer
für weise ob schnaps whisky wir machen
auch für korn also verteilt sich über
deutschland teilweise haben wir ein
bisschen europa in italien ein paar
kunden mit weinfässern in polen schnaps
fässer also das muss schon ein roland
verwey gemacht für wissen es nicht
[Musik]
um haben wir jetzt ein stück eiche wo
später fast draus werden
wir haben's geviertelt die jahresringe
gehen solange wir würden jetzt hier
runter schneiden und hier unterscheiden
und somit haben wir immer stehen die
jahresringe
[Musik]
und die laube eingespannt
v
[Musik]
die holz auswahl beim fass bau ist
entscheidend ich muss immer stehende
jahresringe haben die jahres reagieren
so lang und diese hellen striche die wir
hier sehen sind die markt strahlen die
marktstraßen bilden eine sperrschicht
dass die flüssigkeit so lang nicht
auslaufen kann
während die mark strahlen jetzt so lange
würde das fast immer aus laufen egal wie
ich mich anstrengen um es nicht zu
bekommen
zum ausführen werden die späne genommen
die beim bearbeiten der 1 darum
angefallen sind damit wir den geschmack
nicht verfälschen kann jetzt keine
kiefer nehmen sonst winter hat sich
schmecken
also nehme ich auch die eigenen spiele
von den einzelnen fast darum beim hobeln
und damit machen wir jetzt im fass ein
feuer setzen daher richtig brennt dann
können wir sehen wie wichtig europa
fahrt und durch dieses feuer mit den
spänen kann ich verschiedene
geschmacksrichtungen aus der arche
rausholen das wird jetzt ein rotwein
fast 300 liter inhalt und da kriegen wir
durch das feuer muskat und vanille
geschmack aus der reichen mit raus so
wie der winzer an gesagt hat so kriegt
er sein fasst also wenn wir wenn wir
jetzt einen schönen rotwein haben dann
nimmt man für den cognac nimmt man
einige für den weinbrand für den whisky
man kann auch für für einen grappa eiche
neben der wird dann halt brown gibt es
hier verschiedene braune sorgten körper
die sehr lecker schmecken
ansonsten wenn die ganzen korn haben
nimmt man eine eine esche weil die fahrt
nicht so stark dass gibt nur einen
schönen goldgelben ton
da bleibt der kornweihe ist mein kopf
muss weiß bleiben
schäfer wir am boden einrichten wollen
schild hat für uns den vorteil weil es
innen drin diese kleinen wagen hat jetzt
hier und wenn die reifen ja darum sind
presst sich ganz fest zusammen und so
wie es ein kleines bisschen feucht wird
kürzer auf es dient für uns als
sicherheit noch mal extra zum abdichten
schiff ist geschmacksneutral verändert
somit den inhalt nicht presst sich
zusammen wie pergamentpapier ich musste
also nicht mit einberechnet als toleranz
oder abmaße und das kann nicht verrotten
weiß vom wasser her kommt kennt
feuchtigkeit kann also nicht anfangen zu
bauen oder zu schimmeln und dadurch das
nicht schmeckt also top ist alles natur
wenn ich jetzt silikon ema haben wir nur
in essig stichwort kannst du nicht
machen wird in holzhausen
jetzt ziehen wir hier überall in den
kopf und halsbereich also nur in dieses
stück überall in jeder einzelne fuge
zwischen den daumen ein blatt schilf ein
weil wir da mehr die note eine frist
dadurch ist es da ein bisschen
geschwächt worden
und da dient uns richtig so zur
sicherheit noch mal das ist uns am kopf
nicht läuft
die löcher für die stadtmauer den reifen
zusammen jetzt wird er ändert so jetzt
haben wir unseren kopf reifen zusammen
bietet ist immer zur sicherheit dass man
ein bisschen kreide
damit da nicht rutschten wir jetzt
aufschlagen weil die kreide macht schön
stumpf und beim wolfener hohe stimme so
schön dass die neat nebeneinander haben
[Musik]
fast hatten sehr schönen klang sagen wir
das nicht
ich bin der sechste der oder die sechste
generation die den familienbetrieb
messerschmidt weiterführt vermutlich
kommt und ohne siebter dazu entsteht
erst mal sternen sie sollen sie alle
erstmal ausleben und dann werden wir
sehen
ich muss ja noch ein bisschen bis ich
rente kriegen egal ob bauer kriegen
sollte jemals und da ist noch ein
bisschen zeit dafür ist ein bisschen
wasser die spree runter wenn mein sohn
in den beruf mit einsteigen möchte denk
ich mal wenn ein berufskollege ausbildet
wird aber mir lagen sowie bei uns immer
war jeder beim verteilen der
unterstützung ist eben bei mir sehr
schwer gleicher einzelkämpfer bin ich
hab gar nicht stellte nerlinger und
damit fein unterstützung schon weg immer
man könne ja wenn man selbständig ist
weil wir haben stoßzeiten untergeht
ähnlich und genau denn wenn ich weg bin
denn wo in aller welt haben aber man
kann es so schön machen wir hatten
schöne zu hause man hat mal feierabend
hat man seinen spaß und das ist so
ab und zu mal im urlaub da macht man
natürlich in richtung ausgefallene pro
woche aber wenn es dazu
[Musik]
ist eine herzensangelegenheit und macht
man eben
[Musik]